how's it going red mine espíritu path
and welcome to the wonderful game called
journey holy [ __ ] look at that I'm super
cold
where's banked I messed that [ __ ]
alright I'm super happy at least because
we're gonna continue this uh and we're
hopefully gonna finish it as well I
don't know how long we have left I like
that he walks slower there you are
bang bang bang bang Bang's you got a
really long tail there hello bang are ya
oh good job Aang well the snow
disappeared when it did that that's
awesome
luckily the game has not been spoiled to
me I've been told that it has like a
really epic ending and I tried to like
skim through comments and hopefully
nothing would be and spoiled to me but
here we are finally at the mountain oh
[ __ ] Bank I'm scared I don't know what I
feel about this Bank oh and my tail
burns out that wasn't pointless jump
we're so slow now bang you can't slide
in the snow but you can slide in son
I love the [ __ ] movements and how
they hello Thank You Bank you're welcome
hate that I'm man what is he doing bank
the bank did I miss something what is a
what Bank I think you're calling a
snowstorm we better hurry
come on we don't have time to talk to
statues chases bang come on I know you
have a long tail and all and I know you
try to be cool in all that ah gallop oh
we have to go behind them I get it that
was what bank you could have just told
me that you could have just told me that
oh you told me now well I don't care
shut up Bain don't try to be cool now
I'll shut the snow is coming
I can see your butt banged your skirt is
lifting
it's not very attractive look at that
how about friends this is working
swimmingly I'll already get a friend to
play with you it's so so I love your
bank when this is our do you ever want
to go on a trip together like a real
journey we could go to Paris and we
could chill maybe maybe get it go to
Napoli and get her got a pizza how about
that are you done with that but Matt
police in Italy
well I can't know everything shall I how
do you duck well I'm flying back
I didn't mean to fly let's just go
faster you're too slow for me thanked
come on Percy Oh shet the storm is going
you really don't got to take the money
I'm on bag
I'm praise day over there I wonder if I
could dye it
I didn't know that yet I love how the
coat gets filled with this no it's
awesome very detailed [ __ ] it looks like
I'm gonna come evil or some [ __ ] like
that
ha ha bah
[ __ ] you should have told me about this
Bank
I yelling I'm a-ok
well the journey continues we made it
we're inside the mountain ambras it's
gonna go
splendid gently I also been told though
that you know the eagle time and all
that that's like what is it Bank tell me
you love me o SS way I love you to me
it's it's what happened and we're
discovering like what happened to and
our past or our culture what what it
octopus you gotta be phrasing you're
free you're welcome
I Arctic post can I ride you
just for today I need a ride bro oh sure
he froze again no poor octopus stay
alive man no if you do it crazy
Octopussy you're alive my friend
Bengt save deer whoa Wow whoa dragons
are guarding this place now
I guess the Dragons took over and ruin
everything all right I think we're gonna
go here bang I'm not gonna hold your
hand if that's what you're saying
can you give me some powers to fly
please give me thank you
jeez more more power
thank you fly on the wings of power free
Lovington pills reaching the stars above
clamping my blood fog never gotta be a
songwriter god damn it that's another
dream
I look up your skirt bang do you like
that I think he likes it a little bit
Oh finally we're inside somewhere not
your butt though except your mom what is
this hello oh we gotta talk to these oh
it's so warm and beautiful now I like
this hiya die Oh what luck at die
yeah I'm happy to be I'm really happy
whoa not that happy oh I'm I'm that
happy okay check are we supposed to fly
up here yes we are yes we are cool
what's up sorry time the castle and the
clouds and stuff happen all right that
was a good story really good so it's one
of my favorite and we're out in the
[ __ ] freezing I'm Swedish bang so
this is actually normal for me don't
worry about it don't worry well actually
your Swedish - I forgot sorry this is
like our natural habitant oh [ __ ] we
gotta jump over here I know Bank I'm
scared - I'm going first
no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
fight it bang bang save me for heaven's
sake
bang don't stop beg I regret nothing I
regret nothing no way why am I still
flying why am i doing down here
banged you come back to me you idiot I'm
sorry I thought it was a good idea I'm
really sorry
are you angry are you angry at me
hi bang bang yeah I'm sorry alright
I am a today hi hey come on look I'm
like you're young I'll make your tail
really long
that sounded weird hi hey hey I'm really
sorry okay
I'll buy a hot chocolate when we come
back okay I'll give you a hot chocolate
it's out okay I'm gonna cut because I
[ __ ] up here I really did
I think Bank is pissed at me I feel bad
now I thought I was gonna jump okay how
was I supposed to know oh this guy is
patient I thought I would go on without
him is your feet cold
oh my kidding we don't have feet good
one bagged good one why are we singing
Tetris blocks anyway
I don't know I thought tattooed blocks
would be another song
I don't know this is my opinion do you
think we can make it across will you be
angry if I fall again
well you don't be angry bang I said I'm
sorry jeez give me powers I'll let you
go first I'm scared I'll wait here
sorry bang sorry oh that's how you did
it well you could have told me that
Oh like that carpet still does its job I
don't have to walk on it say that wasn't
so hard right bang yes
stupid people only falling now it looks
like this adventure are we coming closer
to the mountain yeah we're up in the
mountain that Wow
bang oh man oh [ __ ]
thought I was gonna fly away it's really
freaking freezing man Jase I didn't sign
up for this [ __ ] goddamn first extreme
haze now extreme cold it's like what the
hell do they want from me [ __ ]
there's dragons banged don't free all
stop there's a million of them don't
panic but I think we're [ __ ]
alright we're really close to the
mountain down Jon panic oh wait does it
octopus
what what oh [ __ ] think we should have
stopped by the pillar I know I know I
want to go in this house we can live
here we can redecorate it it oh [ __ ]
dragon I'm scared
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
what the [ __ ] are you doing back get out
of there whoa bang what the [ __ ]
begged are you okay bang bang oh thank
god
thought you were dead man well I don't
ever do that again what the [ __ ] what
are you doing you crazy [ __ ] bangs
Jade says so you want to get yourself
killed
I know they got a heart attack man all
right stay together now I see something
over here I want to shake it out
nevermind too far all right Bank degrees
good okay this time around
stealth have you ever played this
honored or the thief games well I can
tell I can tell you haven't Jesus ah but
go there we go
freaking win man it's like they don't
even want us to succeed the mountains is
over here somewhere so I guess we got to
go here but I don't I don't even know oh
[ __ ]
Oh more dragons oh [ __ ] we're [ __ ] bag
hide in the house hide in the house I
had a mouse no no no no no big what are
you doing
wait for me okay it's like are you sure
this is a back I'm going back I'm going
back I don't like this okay
way-hey
ah
I'll shed
okay all right man I just want to get
this done then we'll get hot chocolate
all right
I want extra marshmallows oh it's bad
I'm a one thing
Oh stealth styles remember the stuff yes
god damned ragas man they want to
prevent this from honcho choco conk oh
whatever it's like they never even had
chocolate and they want to ruin it for
everyone else I don't know why I keep
calling a chocolate uh my bank stealth
mission don't worry about it I know
exactly what I'm doing I played these
games
you haven't oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] flambe
alright thank all right you are crazy
you're a crazy son of a [ __ ]
alright hurry up I gotta fly I can't fly
hey where are you going why there did
you really think that was a good idea
fine
it's cuz in here bang we could decorate
the walls maybe put a furnace in here
what I miss a coal maybe we can have
like a sandbox so we could enjoy it
alright yeah okay we're going fine see
you later possible future house fine ah
this one is difficult to reach
now Vanna
no plan oh you're just going back
clambake oh oh I just saved your ass
bank
I just saved your ass I distract them
what do I get
bang punch by thank you thank you
oh thank god is easier to walk here that
was crazy bang that was freakin crazy
I think we're nearing the the
mountaintop now it should be anywhere I
wonder what's on the mountaintop
that's bad a bit oh it's octopus is a 12
octopuses i octopuses for dinner if I
could but I can't so I don't actually I
don't like them actually have them here
in LA it's not it's not an octopus is
actually squids
it's like gooey and shed and I'm like
nope if they fry them no no way no no
what happened here this is the main
temple
let's put some life into this place bank
I'll do that I'll do the tentacles and
you can do the carpets I can fly a
little now at least
yeah I default alright I think we need
all of them to open those doors
come on carpet mouth already
small ones doesn't want to melt
oh they keep phrasing we got to be
faster
bang tell o shat bang you could have
told me that
hello friend this aren't possible new
home
oh we follow the tentacles yes this is
just like that
I don't even need that one I don't even
need that one you see that [ __ ] bang
that's what we call lead skills what's
up oh this is it is it it this is it I
don't know why I did it random jump
there but maybe because I'm happy and
excited but still I'm a little sad
because that means our journey comes to
an end you know what I'm saying bang of
course he did
or a castle magnificent
this [ __ ] wind would just stop whoa
we still got a far along me far the road
to go I don't know what I just said that
god damn it now by this wind just feels
like a way to slow down the gameplay
right now getting a lot tired
oh [ __ ] I didn't ask for this
where did all the people go like what
happened to this place I know the
octopus's Dragon King
our shed
Oh No nuts all the way not all the way I
don't hurry up bang
hurry up I think we got to go here
I agree
all right I don't have a lot of time
banked the wind does not play games
I can barely sing anymore it's quite sad
right sided me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
no mana
I can barely sing what is Begg doing oh
[ __ ] you're crazy man
you're crazy you can't fly in a weather
like this it's like flying in it I don't
even know anymore
whoa we still have a low Wow Wow
bang I'm scared for real I don't know if
I can make it anymore okay it's official
I can make it better be like a mud
fountain of virgins whoa what the hell
is going this is crazy
I kept battling sick but here's my
number so call me bang
come on
I'm scared why is it thunder up here is
that even possible
I thought Thunder only happens when
there's heat
I want to go to the Thunder even though
it doesn't make sense it's just so
[ __ ] freezing
I actually feel cold just playing this
you feel the same way Rose I don't know
it's weird maybe it is cold I don't know
it's winter after all or maybe you're an
Australian
it's crazy you crazy Australian City you
don't even know what you're talking
about
oh you didn't say anything well that's a
bucket there for you I left it there
just a little fire the bagged that's a
little father I always admire your
salmon avenge you were always the
toughest one but hey we always managed
to make our way through it no matter how
hard the times was right right thing do
you remember that time that dragon
nearly killed you I nearly killed me I
try to save you but you just ran you're
crazy I think I might have to amputate
my legs because they're freezing this is
worse than climbing Mount Everest
no I can't move anymore bang I'm a
little scared what's what's what's
what's going on bang bang what's
happening I don't feel so good
thank sing to me sing to me bang where's
your scarf no we're dying bang I want
you to know you are the greatest you are
the greatest banged I love you don't
leave me
stay with me step back
I know a lot of you friends are scared
by this I don't know why whoa ooh big
top feet W